galleons Kenny s is quite frankly one of
the best to ever play CS I mean the man
is in contention for greatest offer of
all time
he's a major champion and he's an
artiste that's why this week on top ten
we decided to count down the 10 best
Kenny a skills of his entire career from
AWP kills because frankly we just love
KS oh one more thing did you guys know
that the s and Kenny S stands for a
shirt okay well maybe not but we sell
some pretty sick t-shirts here at the
square you sports now and if you want to
check this one out and the rest of our
collection and link to our online
merchant partment will be pinned in the
comment section below now without
further ado guys let's get on with it if
the 10 best NES kills a bulldog kicking
off our list at number 10 is a clutch
that is as hilarious as it is epic Kenny
I think we want to the grand finals of
IEM gamescom 2015 kenny s found himself
alone on site with two TS m players
gunning for well so now it's on kenny
1 we two about 30 seconds left the
french chopper took advantage of some
unlucky pistol play from Kerrigan and
finished off the 1v2 clutch with just a
single point of help
canidius punches the round oh my lord
that should not happen Kerrigan just
gonna charge him down is it miss quite a
few pistol shots Kenny yes II wanna kill
that is why possibly one of the most
depressing things I've seen so far few
individual matchups in csgo hold as much
weight as Kenny s versus Guardian and
perhaps no match symbolized this rivalry
more than envious vs. Navi at ESL one
cologne 2015 where the world's best
snipers ended a chaotic 1v1 in an
unexpected fashion and now it's all on
Guardian will you try and hope y'all be
get the shot on sway pics is he gonna
try and go huge it
and make it three Nobby coming in at
number eight is a flick you'll
definitely have to watch twice oh that
is fast
taking on ninjas in pyjamas at Dreamhack
Malmo semi-finals
Kenny s was on a tear as he made sure
nip knew who the world's best oper
really was and he's gonna have some
hungry ninjas in his face very soon oh
that's is fast put that in your pipe and
smoke it
think you get pretty high if you did
that's a quite a shot from Kenny I was
looking at it any Wednesday's although
he's gonna get pushing this doubt ken
yes number 7 on our list is a 1v2 match
ending clutch that sends Bardolph d DK
and launders through a range of emotions
Kenny now one versus two you would have
been against him this is his I thought
I've heard you cast so many nice clothes
really say I'm just looking at it any
Wednesday's although he's gonna get
pushing this
[Music]
throughout his career Kenny asses had to
take on the role of hard carry for his
team and at number six we have a play
where Kenny proves that he's a human
highlight reel with some of the poshest
plays we've ever seen unfortunately for
ni p they play the victim role for the
second time on this list oh my god Kenny
s with three insane kills and he has
time like the each element is gonna win
the round is he got time yeah he's got
home unbelievable leave this man though
is this actually is this happening this
just happened it was happening it's like
guys - lets go in kill everyone else but
no Kenny has finally turns up coming in
at number 5 on this list is Kenny asses
incredible 1v3
at dreamhack London 2015 getting clapped
on home soil can't be good for your
morale and neither is losing 62 but
Kenny as cold as ever pulled off this
disgusting 1v3 on inferno that destroyed
a comeback for these up-and-coming Brits
okay yes stuck in the sight finding more
that's brilliant - Kenny yes
the noscope on the 3rd this guy's
absolutely insane huh these poor guys
from ni p just can't catch a break
coming in at number four is their third
appearance on this list which harkens
back to Kenny s his early days with
Titan already making a name for himself
as one of the best offers in the world
can you show us exactly how deadly he
could be during Star Series season 12 by
decimating ni P you know one before to
end the Kiana's well Kenny asked with no
armor running around to the side kind of
get to safety he manages to get out
these foes position picks up the fried
on swallow second saw first is causing
oh my goodness so much damaged on hit by
Kenny yes another fry found out again
Kenny s 4 kills in a row and there is
1614 and that is fantastic there from
Kenny s oh my god coming in at number
three is a flick that'll leave you
speechless fighting for a spot at IEM
katowice 2017 g2 faced off against
envyus
and kenny s made sure to remind his
former team that there's simply no one
quite like him so he takes it down and
now they've lost an advantage all of a
sudden it's Kenny and shucks vs. the
world here in Shox the action Kenny
first up the bat he finds a shot but
he's being pressured up close he needs
Shox to support him he's gonna play
people would go oh my god Kenny it's an
incredible killing sixer I don't even
see the flicky hits that shot summit and
it's another round for g2 they're
shooting us again 14 to 7 what was that
last shot who says Kenny has can't rifle
there's no goddamn way that he's gonna
do this
he's got no health Col gonna go breaking
the other up spot on our list is an
insane one before that shows us there is
no bounce to how versatile Kenny is as a
player he doesn't even need an awp to
clutch I am done I am done facing off
against luminosities young Brazilian
squad at the face at stage 3 finals
Kenny put together another highlight
reel and made Anders lose his mind
in
she's late Kenny you know one versus
three and luminosity they are one round
away from match and mappoint here Kenny
adding a single headshot he's got the
double sprays guess one more there is no
goddamn way that he's gonna do this
he's got no health cold gonna go break
Johnny oh joy oh my god the king is here
I'm sorry for criticizing you early
Kenny saying you were off to a cold
start if you were saving it all up for
that one round to keep your team in this
map that's all right now not in a
million years I am done what better way
to cap off this list than with Kenny s
once again bodying the ninjas in pyjamas
yeah
pushes from Titan whatever you can do I
can do better
oh god I'm I need someone to hold me
right now those and I was amazing I
don't I don't know what else to say
three new scopes in the end yeah oh man
that video made me nostalgic for the
classic Ken yes and if you're still here
and you feel the same why not check out
our story of Kenny s our best of kenny
ass he'll watch our podcast with Kenny s
see you next time
[Music]